in downtown kabul is usually crowded
with shoppers
but as the economy is tanking crowds are
thinning and businesses in the major
commercial district are shutting down or
closing early
the foreign reserves that could rescue
afghanistan is sitting in a bank 11 000
kilometers away in the us
but president joe biden is only
releasing half of the funds to
afghanistan the rest is to be shared out
among victims of 911 in the u.s as well
as other attack victims
the 3.5 billion belongs to afghanistan
and the people and if the u.s is paying
this amount to those who lost their
lives in the 9 11 attacks then the u.s
should pay compensation for the 20-year
war and the people who died in
afghanistan
kabul is a city under pressure
many can barely afford to eat
most of us sleep with empty stomachs
because we don't have jobs to find money
and feed our families
like before in someone was distributing
bread to the poor and there were
hundreds of poor and starving people
fighting over one piece of bread and i
was thinking it's better to die than
being disrespected this much
extreme hunger is nationwide
it's estimated more than half of the 39
million afghans are suffering
the u.n says the afghan economy is in
free fall and so are its people
the us says it will use the release
funds to buy much needed aid but not
fire the taliban which it doesn't
recognize as the legitimate government
taliban leaders say it's not america's
money to give away
afghanistan
the people of afghanistan want their
rights the funds that are blocked in the
u.s belong to the afghans and it's their
rights to take them the decisions made
about these funds should be made by us
the islamic emirate
others have displayed their anger at
biden's decision on the streets of the
capital
but however they express themselves most
here say the money belongs to
afghanistan and they desperately need it
laura berger manly al jazeera